لم تبلغ العلاقات بين واشنطن وتل ابيب هذا
المستوى من قبل حتى بنى فتره اوباما
وتوافقه مع ايران بشان الاتفاق النووي لم
يحصل ما نشاهد هذا اليوم اي استدعى سفير
اسرائيلي لدى واشنطن فالرئيس الامريكي
يجاهر علانيه من قلب واشنطن حيث مقر لجنه
الشؤون العامه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه
ولوبيات اخرى ليقول لن ادعو نتنياهو الى
البيت الابيض وفي اسرائيل نتنياهو يمتص
هذه الصدمه بعد حاله الرفض ليخفف من وطئه
الخلاف ويصفه بالعربيه اما ما لم يعد
غريبا فهو علاقته نتنياهو بوزرائه خصوصا
ان يدرك ان اسرائيل ليست نجمه اخرى على
علم امريكا
افاد ديوان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان
رئيس الوزراء او عزا لاعضاء حكومته بعدم
التعقيب على تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بشان التعديلات القضائيه وبعد ان
اعلن رفضه للضغوط الامريكيه على حكومته
قال نتنياهو ان التحالف بين الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل لا يتزعزع رغم وجود
خلافات عرضيه بينهما
كما تعلمون سبق للولايات المتحده واسرائيل
مرت بخلافات عرضيه سابقه لكن يؤكد لكم ان
التحالف بين ديمقراطيه عظيمه وديمقراطيه
قويه وفخوره ومستقله مثل اسرائيل في قلب
الشرق الاوسط هو تحالف لا يمكن زعزعته
وكان رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قد اعرب عن
قلقه ازاء ما وصلت اليه الامور في اسرائيل
وقال انه قلق عليها وانها لا يمكن ان
تواصل في هذا المسار ودع بايدن رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الى ايجاد تسويه
حقيقيه وتخلي عن مشروع التعديلات القضائيه
وتوفير حل للوضع الصعب الذي تعيشه الدوله
وفق تعبيره كما اشار بايدن الى انه لا
يعتزم دعوه نتنياهو لزياره واشنطن في
المدى القريب
لا اعرف ما اذا كانوا قد بلغوا نقطه تحول
لكنه وضع صعب ويجب عليهم حله ماذا تعمل ان
يفعل رئيس الوزراء بشان هذا القانون
بالذات
امل ان يتخلوا عنه
قال وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار
بن كثير في حديث لاذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
على الرئيس بايدن والاداره الامريكيه ان
يفهموا ان اسرائيل هي دوله مستقله وليست
نجمه اخرى في عالم الولايات المتحده
اقل موقع ولا الاسرائيلي ان مسؤولين
امريكيين حذروا رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ومقربين منه من استفزاز الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن وقالوا ان تحذيرهم لنتنياهو
ينبعوا تحديدا من ان بايدن يعرف نفسه كا
صهيوني ولديه خطوط حمراء حيث انه لا يحتمل
المساس بما يصفها بالديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه ونقل موقع ولا عن مصادر رسميه
اسرائيليه ان بايدن بعث برساله شخصيه
وسريه نقلها السفير الامريكي في القدس
توماس
عبرت عن غضب البيت الابيض من اقاله
نتنياهو لوزير دفاعه
والفت الموقع الى ان اقاله جلاند ادت الى
حاله من الغليان دفعت واشنطن لتوجيه رسائل
شديده اللهجه مفادها ان الاداره الامريكيه
تتوقع منه وقفه تشريعات القضائيه بشكل
فوري واضافت مصادر للموقع ان مستشارين
وضعوا امام الرئيس الامريكي خيارات للضغط
على نتنياهو منها الغاء مشاركته في مؤتمر
الديمقراطيه لكن جميع الخيارات استبعدت
بعد خطاب نتنياهو الذي اعلن فيه تجميد
عمليه التعديل القضائي والبدء في مفاوضات
مع المعارضه